hey everybody and welcome to a
hard-hitting wild ride with stevo
this week we have an absolute legend of
professional wrestling
one of the most badass dudes on the
planet but in fact
he's about as nice and just sweet of a
guy as you could ever hope to me man we
had a really good time with him
so let's get into it ladies and
gentlemen
chris jericho yeah dude yes
now let me ask you a question to start
off right away do you remember when we
saw each other last
yeah in europe in 2011 in wales okay i
didn't remember that
yeah in wales backstage we had a show
you had the big room
and i had the little room yeah we were
playing a fuzzy gig and i saw it was
like a university or something it was in
cardiff
right and uh it said you know like
fozzie and also stevo's
crazy show whatever yeah i forget what i
was calling it yeah and it was like we
happened to meet in the hallway and i
was like yeah it's really cool man i
remember thinking what a great guy
when you're overseas too you see
somebody dude like you become best
friends instantly right
for sure so that's cool that you
remember that was that was an awesome
night it was a great experience man it
was
and so you met scott randolph yeah he
met in the lobby earlier
up at the front we got the gorgeous paul
briskey he's he's hot hey
thanks usually when you get in a van
with three dudes and one of them is
really hot in l.a
it's not uh this type of situation yeah
exactly
right so yeah dude says so uh you got a
new book coming out
what number is it is that this is book
number five
holy [ __ ] it's book number five up your
game steve
i'm working on book number two right now
that's good yeah anytime you can do it a
second time you know you got a hit
right it's like any time you've done a
lot of different shows as of i
the first season is hard to get but it's
really hard to get the second season
that's the hardest one right if you can
get the [ __ ] second season or get a
second book
right you know you did something right
on the first for sure how long does it
take you to write a book well
this one's different so okay so i had
four kind of
autobiography stories all that sort of
[ __ ] road tails and stuff
this one uh my very first match was
october 2nd
1990 in ponoka alberta just outside of
calgary
and i wrote it down when i got home
match one
and i wrote it down 30 years later match
in jacksonville florida october 7 2020
um i had kept a list of every single
match i ever had
wow so this book is called the complete
list of jericho with all of these
matches
included every single one that i've ever
had
is in this book along with other you
know essays and top tens and a lot of
the things
and at first i was like should i really
do this like will people care
and then about a year ago i bought a
rush book that had every gig
that rush had ever played since 19
[ __ ] 74 and i was like
listen there's a fan base that wants to
see this stuff for sure
that's right right thing is like your
gimmick anyway right
it is the gimmick so so it was the
complete list of jericho
and then you guys will appreciate this
so i took it to my publisher this is
four books in now
is it all with the same publisher well
there was two three but the most recent
one
uh it was the new york times bestseller
congratulations yay
whatever but point being i'm like dude
like i got this idea for a book
every match ever he goes that's two it's
too direct it's too
uh it's it's too esoteric for your
demographic or whatever type of [ __ ]
he was talking i was like all right
i'll just publish it myself no no no
they're like wait wait wait wait oh
we'll do it
yeah yeah yeah and i was just like oh
yeah no but i know they didn't i did it
myself
and now i'll never use the publisher
again wow because it
gets a hit right out of the gate because
you do it yourself obviously you do it
with a company
but the but the royalties you get off
the book by publishing it yourself it
blows it out of the water
i bet yeah that's really interesting
yeah were you able to get like the
nielsen scan
whatever uh you know sales recorded to
make it a new york times bestseller well
i don't know exactly how much you need
because it's gone down over the years so
so what year was your first book 2011
okay
so my my first one was 2007 second was
2010.
so the book business since then has gone
completely
south right it's like the dvd business
or something
but audiobooks are probably still
popular that would suggest that it
requires less sales to make to get on
the list that's right
so that's what i have to do now is find
out because i check i'm a i'm a numbers
guy
so i look i refresh my phone like every
hour how many have i sold because it
just came out
yesterday right i think that the ticket
is
and this is my plan for for when mine
comes out
is uh to generate as much pre-sales as
you possibly bingo
because like on the day that the book
actually goes on sale
all of the pre-sales combined totaled
towards
the week one to week one right so what
i'm gonna do when mine comes out
i'm gonna say hey everybody my book just
went on pre-sale the only way to get an
autographed copy is to order it on
pre-sale and you're gonna get it
autographed before anybody else have
done it that's smart yeah i think i
think i'll get more pre-sales that way
because for me
it's once it goes paperback it's got to
say new york times bestseller
absolutely it has to so that's a great
idea and actually i have to
see doing steve's show stevo's show i
gotta
work on that because we did a great
number of pre-sales but here's the other
thing
i don't know how many things you guys
had during the pandemic it's like well
we can't
uh do it because like apparently
publishing book publishing
was at a standstill because of the
pandemic
i don't know maybe they were so busy
that they had like no i had
i have my own brand of champagne and i
wanted gold foil for this one edition
they said well you can't get gold foil
because of the pandemic
you can get silver foil though so
apparently the gold foil
is very covered uh transmitting friendly
as as are the publishing mills i think
it's less to do with
with transmission of cobit and more to
do with supply chains
could be that that's where it was
disrupted so much so that was disrupting
the gold foil
uh cartels yeah but it was like the
excuse
in kovid like everybody was like sorry
every every phone call it's like yo
you'll be experiencing longer wait times
due to covet like it's just it was just
a blanket like
we're working lazy [ __ ] had the
best excuse for the last childhood yeah
exactly
and at the same time it it really like
it's like with bicycles skateboards like
on you know
almost single action sports like it
it was such a boom for so many
industries right that they sold out of
everything that
they had and then you had shortages just
because there was insane demand
i i think you know now we're getting
into this but but it's it's something
very
very viable to talk about as bad as the
pandemic was for
some businesses for others they went
through the roof like you mentioned like
i love to ride my bike and blew out the
tire on my bike i went to take it in and
we got no tires
everybody's riding their bikes like you
said skateboarding i'm sure was the same
etc etc
so this guy's like dude i can't keep
bikes in here this is the busiest
boats bikes skateboards anything
outdoors
that's going through the roof i mean you
would think too that books
would uh be doing pretty well
everybody's stuck at home you know
everybody's by watching netflix and like
amazon and yeah i guess they're probably
afraid people aren't going to the stores
to buy the book so they didn't want to
release it and have it be kind of a dud
yeah but like you said there's so many
ways to read a book now candles and
audios and all that sort of stuff i
think the last three or four books i
bought it was just on a plane
i want to read something just go on your
phone boom there's your book right you
know what i mean so did you do an
audiobook version for yours
i did an audiobook version for book
number so here's the thing
so book number three i got an argument
with the audio
company whatever so they're like we'll
just get somebody else to read it i'm
like fine do it
so they had some guy who's a former
shakespearean author
and he's kind of talking like this and
he's talking about rey mysterio who is
finished is called the 619
which of course is the area code for san
diego he's going and then rey mysterio
did a 619
and i'm like dude i got in so much
trouble for fans because he said 619
not 619. he's pretty he's pronouncing
this word wrong and this one rocks so
when the fourth one came around i said
i'll do the audio book for did you do an
audio for yours
you know the publisher screwed up with
my schedule
and so like so i was able to do like
chapters one and two and then some
weirdo took over right he was the former
shakespearean actor
[Laughter]
i was pissed about it because uh you
know it wasn't me i've started to this
day i've never
acknowledged that there i didn't either
dude i didn't either
promoted it right here i'm saying don't
even don't buy it at me
listen to chapter one and turn that [ __ ]
off yeah don't buy mine either because
probably
back and do it though but dude here's
the thing that is a long
long procedure to do that because you
gotta read it you know and of course if
you
make any mistakes or fumble your word
you do it again
it takes a long time to read 300 pages
man
a week's worth of eight-hour days in the
studio so
i don't know how many audiobooks it sold
but it took a lot
of work to do it so make sure if you're
going to do it you're prepared
because it takes a long time right it
would take you a while
just you're so particular when we film
like a video where steve's like
narrating a story
it's like he'll start a sentence like
stop like let me get that again like
you want it to be right right yeah you
know i'm a real
[ __ ] psycho when it comes to my
content but see and that but that's
that's the reason why i'm saying it's
not just because you're here you've done
a great job as
i'll pat myself on the back again we've
done a great job of staying relevant for
10 25
years not just being oh it's funny
jackass guy or it's wrestler guy there's
so many things we do
because you do take great pride in the
content me too i don't stamp chris
jericho on anything
unless i'm 100 happy with it like the
book came out yesterday and right off
the bat of course because the fans are
great but there was
a typo where it says something like i
was was walking somehow
oh it said was was i'm like [ __ ]
how did i let that second was
get through now listen it's the only
typo in the whole book
thousands of words but that one of
course they found it right away
how did that get through like i just
want to edit it out everywhere just go
and
cross out the second ones but that's
very important to do that
because you know why your fan base
can see through it if you're not into it
they can tell this is [ __ ]
right steve was just doing this for a
paycheck or whatever which you would
never do and neither would i
at this point but people can see that
and that's why a lot of these guys and
girls that do stuff like that
they don't they don't have the longevity
because people see through
it's just a cash it's a cash grab yeah
it doesn't it's not cool you know you
can see that
right yeah i answered a couple questions
this morning on like the the customer
service page
like how do we know this is like a real
autograph i'm like steve would never
like i don't even know how to write the
like never never never a million times
never
fake anything especially his autograph
right
right yeah for sure i mean i i've made
enough videos where
they sh i show myself of course
and uh and dude how's it how's uh heavy
metal music man
yeah dude we just uh so our band fozzie
i just got the billboard charts today
our new single came out last week and we
debuted i think at 33 so it's our sixth
consecutive top 40 song
and it's just the first week it's our
highest debut ever so when you debut in
the 30s
that means the top 10 is like gonna
happen so that'll be our fourth top ten
so we've done a really good job over the
last
five or so years of really hitting radio
and having the right radio team and
we're on sony records now which gives
you that corporate push
yeah but radio is still super important
i never would have guessed it
it is it is it's actually alive and well
right i uh
i've got some good friends in radio you
would particularly let me shout out my
bro mike
yeah calta in tampa that's right [ __ ]
love my content i remember telling him i
was like dude like
you got to be hurting you know he says
radio is alive and well which makes no
sense because
with all the podcasts with all the
serious and the way everything's just so
fragmented but dude i'll tell you what
like
like la and new york don't have you know
like mainstream rock stations which is
weird because of the biggest cities
but you start getting into the
heartlands every single
you know freaking you know portland
oregon canada wisconsin
you know detroit i know those are
heartlands but uh
peoria wherever you go they have rock
stations michigan has a great one the
banana
and when you get played on those
stations it really builds up your band
and it's very important to get on the
radio to get to that next level and i
never realized it
until we started getting on the radios
without who needs the radio it doesn't
matter
it does because when we got on the radar
that's when we started getting bigger
crowds and bigger offers to play with
other bands and all that sort of stuff
so
um for us to have this this debut in the
top 40 right of the gate it's really big
for us
and it's exciting that's cool you would
appreciate this we did the video
at this place called holiday world in
santa claus
indiana holy [ __ ] i've never heard of
santa santa claus it's a real town
and we're on the voyager
which is the longest wait wait the
voyager of the seas from royal caribbean
not quite dude
then maybe next time this was the
voyager which is the longest
wooden roller coaster in america okay
so we we we locked the camera in the
front of the of the roller coaster
and then i sit here and guitar player
sits here and everybody kind of sits
this way so when it goes around you can
see everybody and then we go through the
thing
six times listening to the song and
lip-syncing it so i got to be the lead
singer and look cool as we're going
because a wooden roller coaster throws
you around and it was just like boom
boom boom boom
and but i still got to be cool lip sync
it you know i am
living inside this night man and you can
feel it in your stomach like like
you guys did crazy stuff but going on a
roller coaster six times in a row on
that
thing dude half the band was throwing up
one dude threw up on the roller coasters
we were going of course
we had to edit it that's not very rock
and roll
to be puking
but it was just it's never been done
before and it's just it was a really
cool idea but man
the human body is not made to do six of
these wooden roller coasters yeah within
the course of the hour
all of us were just [ __ ] up at the end
like i said two guys were puking and
even me
because i couldn't be nauseous during it
because i got to look cool
be the be the front man but when it was
done the last one when i was like dude
i'm done
like i will never go on a roller coaster
sweating profusely more inside your
insides are all shaking up and you just
feel that like
oh but it turned out great because all
that matters is the finished product
and the the video did like a million
views in a couple weeks so it came out
of the gate pretty hot it was
amazing so good that was cool so do you
have
tour dates for fozzie now when did you
we do it's funny because we had a tour
booked
in march and april of 2020 that we had
sold
tons of tickets for and then of course
covid came so we postponed it i think to
like july then he got postponed october
same thing so four postponements and now
we're going out in september
which is great because all the tickets
that were bought before the lockdown
not a lot of people uh got refunds yeah
so we still have so right because now
everybody's going out right every
[ __ ] band is going up so at least we
have
our tickets pretty much sold i had the
same experience man people held on to
the tickets they did right
99 of them and they were they were
totally able to get refunds when's your
tour
i mean [ __ ] i'll uh announce it in the
next week or so
but uh i got my first date august great
so that's the time frame august we have
a couple festivals in july
uh like i said these like you know brat
days in sheboygan wisconsin and these
types of things
taco fest in jacksonville but they're
all rock radio
stations in these cities and then that
leads us to september where we go out
for
a six-week tour i saw foo fighters did a
full sold out how many people is that
that's probably
15 000 yeah it depends how much they
they block off the stage
at least 15 25 at the most 15 to 18
depending
if that's not a testament to like it's
open everything's over it's open
they're doing one of the forum i think
in a couple weeks here as well right
yeah
so i mean that's great man you know how
you know uh
like everything's open this is when you
got hundreds of people showing up for a
pube party
steve hosted a pube festival cube
fashion yeah i just had a meet-up with
uh
i got as many people to show up i said
you gotta have uh lots of pubic hair and
bring your own shaver
oh yeah i'm collecting as much as i can
to make my own sasquatch suit
made out of human pews yeah that's
there are some characters there oh i'm
sure right big time
so i gotta say i was kind of surprised
to see you
uh like you're distilled wrestling
there's an
aw yeah dude so this came up about
two and a half years ago where uh
there's this guy out of jacksonville
named tony kahn
his family owns the jacksonville jaguars
i know about it well because i'm buddies
with darby allen
yeah of course darby's great
he's with the yeah and we made him a
star
like right out of the gate because one
of the things we had to do is we need to
make homegrown stars it can't just all
be the jerichos that i've named
and darby i worked with darby in week
three in uh philadelphia you had this
idea like why don't you know he's like
why don't you like tie my hands behind
my back with tape and then we can
wrestle with i'm like how are you gonna
[ __ ] do that he goes
well i'll show you this video i'm like
the dude i taped his hands behind his
back and he's doing all these flips and
he's beating me up and it was just like
the raddest thing and i was like dude
and here's the best part
i said the week before i was doing
something i said ride your skateboard
down the ramp and jump off and attack me
goes
i don't know if i really want to do that
i'm like dude you don't understand like
wrestling fans have never seen this
before he goes right what kind of goes
against the skateboard culture whatever
whatever the unwritten code of
skateboarding was
and i was like dude i respect that but
you got to trust me on this
that skateboard has become one of the
most over things on the show because
people go [ __ ] nuts for it because
he's good he just rides down
and rips i skated with him last week
oh really and i was skated with him a
bunch yeah yeah
i probably shouldn't say this but he was
telling me about how uh
he he had an event for uh for aew
where he was like badly injured but just
but didn't want to let on right right
and and he was able to cover
to work his way through it like with an
injury with an injury that's kind of
what we do
i mean you know the show must go on type
thing and it's funny because when i
wrestled him
i was beating up and i grabbed his
skateboard and i tried to like ride it
it's like i fell off like a two-foot
ride there's a gift if you see me
i'm riding on the thing it's not easy to
do but
that's the cool thing about aws the cons
had the the vision
they had the financial backing we had
this great group of guys that didn't
want to go
to wwe that wanted to do something new
myself included and we created this
whole
uh show that's like it's the coolest
wrestling program in the world
dude yeah and yeah you got it on tnt
yeah right out of the gate we had tnt
but if three months in we
renewed for like 200 million dollars for
four years or whatever
so we really had arrived at that point
and then
right after that went straight into this
pandemic where we were wrestling in
front of nobody
like nobody it's it's hard to to wrestle
in front it'd be like a stand-up
comedian telling jokes to the wall
right and i remember like people were
saying i feel so bad for the young guys
having to work in front of no fans i was
like
[ __ ] the young guys they feel bad for me
i've been working in front of thousands
of people since i was 21 years old i
don't know what to do
and so you just kind of had to to to you
know evolve and just
realize that we have a tv audience
that's watching so even there's no
reactions
right you still have to keep the lights
on and then slowly people started coming
back in to where you're like finally a
couple weeks ago we had 5 000 people
sold out in jacksonville for a
pay-per-view it was like it felt like
okay this is what it's all about
yeah this is this is the third man
in the ring where you can feel this
emotion and these these
these chants and just the energy and the
electricity
and it was like oh it's good to be back
man we made it through and now
bring the fans back and we're excited
about that again do you think that
improved
people's skills having to do it in front
of no one now that there's a crowd
in other words did he step up his game
and i'm going to admit to you right now
that i needed to step up my game in a
big way recently
because frankly i got fat
i had to cut out the sugar again and
thank god i
found a cereal that is every bit as
delicious
as all of the unhealthy stuff i loved
when i was a kid
but it has zero grams of sugar per
serving
13 grams of protein per serving
only four grams of net carbs is
so delicious and it's keto friendly
grain free soy
free gluten free low carb
and man it is called magic spoon and
i'm almost embarrassed to admit how much
of this stuff i'm eating i ordered
16 boxes the other day because i love it
so much dude and you got to try it
and if you go to magicspoon.com stevo
to get yourself a variety pack with
frosted
cocoa fruity and
uh what's the other one peanut butter oh
yeah dude they're all so good
and uh if you go to magicspoon.com get
your variety pack
then you use the promo code steve we get
five dollars at checkout
and i'm telling you i'm eating like the
little kid that was just
out of control with cap'n crunch and
everything
and i'm actually losing weight i'm so
happy about it
this is the best thing that's happened
to me man and i want you to try it
so one more time man get over to
magicspoon.com
stevo and use the promo code stevo for
five dollars off
this stuff kicks so much ass magic spoon
backs it with the 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason at
all they will refund your money no
questions asked
now let's talk about stepping up our
game
it did but what it took away is is like
in wrestling we call it being over being
popular right
and we didn't really know for sure like
darby for example when crowds started
coming out they're going nuts for darby
had we had
eight months more of crowds he'd be even
bigger than he is there's a couple other
guys orange cassidy jungle boy guys like
that
and now that we have the crowd we kind
of had to put everybody on pause but now
that live reaction tells you right away
who's popular and who's right right
that's the barometer right i feel like
if you get hit with a chair with no
crowd it hurts a lot more than
it does
this venue in jacksonville which is
right next to the football stadium
it's called daley's place it's an
outdoor venue dude
we were wrestling in the summer it's
like 100 and [ __ ] 10 degrees on a
july in florida
and conversely in the winter it's
getting down like 40 42 degrees you know
in february
those chair shots hurt a lot more in
february than they do in july as well
all that stuff it's like when you play
football when it's cold you catch a
football in your hand you're like
[ __ ]
that's what it was like just like
chopping somebody or anything ah it's
cold
but anyways we're going back to arenas
july 1st on july 7th
and we're going back on the road across
america again so uh we're excited about
that
i kind of don't even want to ask because
i know it's just so like
cliche but but we're in the same
situation where we're doing
super physical [ __ ] like at an age right
where it like
doesn't make sense to be doing the kind
of presentation
and i know that everyone like because we
got a new jackass movie coming out in
october
and everyone like the only question
what's it like being doing jackass this
old aren't you too old to be doing it
i know my answer is and it's the same as
it ever was just our bones break easier
you know it takes less to knock us out
right right and longer to wake up
i think it's it and like you said this
is all like
how old were you when you started doing
jackass i mean [ __ ] i started making
videos when i was 15. okay so there you
go
jack i started i was 26. gotcha so that
was 15.
so i've been wrestling since i was 19.
it's just what we do
right you know like if you started doing
it now it'd be a totally different
story you'd be like [ __ ] this but for me
it's like i never
feel like obvious age-wise somebody's
like
you're 50 like i'm 50. who me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
i don't feel that way i don't act that
way because i've been on the road doing
this since i was 19.
so um you watching maybe you're a little
slower at times but
it's all show business and action
personality and charisma
and i can still do the matches at a high
level because that's all i've ever done
i think the biggest piece probably for
you as well and me too
is that we were very fortunate to get
away with doing it for so long without
like
real serious exactly and also be able to
take some time away to do other projects
and other stuff it's not like you've
been doing stunts the whole time or i've
been taking
bumps in the in the ring the whole time
so i think
like that's the that's listening to your
body and having the
what's the word i'm looking for having
the the level of
fame or notoriety where you can do that
i'm only going to wrestle
15 times this year yeah we'd really like
to do more
15 is good for me okay whatever you
whatever you need chris
you know and that helps because you know
your body if i had to do like back in
the day
god man we were doing 200 shows a year
200 matches a year
sometimes more i could never do that now
but i can have 15 to 20 great matches
every year and then do another 30
weeks of tv with promos and interviews
and character stuff
to build the story for these matches and
it just makes more money for everybody
around you can't teach experience that's
the one thing you cannot teach yeah
it makes sense that it would be like
it's more special when you do get in the
ring yeah exactly it makes it more of a
of an event and it's not like i'm not a
part-timer i'm on tv every week but
we've told great stories with
all these different elements and
characters to where you can do stuff
every week and you don't have to be
wrestling
and that's what makes it that's what
wrestling is it's the stories
it's the connecting with the audience
that's so much more important
than than the falls that you take in the
ring obviously those
mean something when you do it but it's
all just hooking people
right with that story and those
characters and if you can do that
you'll have a very long career mm-hmm
yeah and
so is it like year-round the aw it's
once a week
that's another great thing like before
in wwe you'd work four times a week
maybe
uh aw we're a television company it's
once a week if we have a pay-per-view we
do
a show on a sunday as well but um yeah
the most part it's all in jacksonville
well
just because of the pandemic oh gotcha
but but the most part it was around
the country and so now like i said july
we're miami we're dallas we're san
antonio we're charlotte
we're going back you know we got a big
show in new york at the arthur ashe
stadium
it's our first new york market show
right in the middle of manhattan at this
giant tennis stadium
in september prudential center in
september so we've got some really big
shows coming up
once again welcoming back all of these
fans who i mean
jacksonville was a great city for us but
we this business
thrives on playing in front of a
different crowd every night what night
of the week is
wednesday wednesday so that's got the
the one
the mma the one championship is on
wednesdays as well
are they you talking about ufc yeah no
no one is a different mma organization
oh one the show one gotcha yeah yeah
yeah it's weird because two the nba
playoffs kind of threw us all off the
last couple months because obviously tnt
is a big nba company
right i mean it's the nba station so
we've been on fridays at 10 o'clock
and you know saturday night and this so
we're kind of all over the place
finally next week we go back to
wednesdays again because that makes a
big difference people are creatures of
habit sure and when you switch you can
tell everybody all night long that we're
switching
and they'll be like what happened to
wednesday night you're not on
so we're excited because you need to be
on your slot
every wednesday at eight people know
they tune in they get into the habit of
it and that's where you build your fan
base
so you're the lead and for the one
because the one comes on like i think
they're on after us yeah
yeah not not this not now because i
think once again nba has thrown
everything into the wind
but one i believe is on after us on
wednesdays
man i gotta say it's pretty impressive
how many revenue streams he got going
you got the
and and podcasting as well how long you
been doing that i was pretty
lucky because i started podcasting in
december of 2013.
okay so it's been almost eight years and
now i mean
i'm sure you know this but there's
literally like a million podcasts
i think it's more like two million more
than that right like dude it's
it's it's insane everybody has one and
that's great if you want to do a podcast
do it
the the the advantage that i had as i
built a fan base
right before so many came in right to
where my podcast is still very
i think it's top 100 in in in in the
states for sure
yeah i just i just looked it up and you
got a 7 500 ratings on it which
okay it's a massive amount okay there
you go i mean yeah i saw you had 700 750
million downloads
it's not 750 i think it's close to about
300 million 300 million
yeah over the course of time so i mean
once again i mean that's
that's i'm very fortunate to have i got
to have you on dude i would love i've
got to have you on for sure i i would
love it yeah
i saw tiger with westwood one which is
the same company
that uh had stone cold for the longest
time so
i wondered if he brought you in he did
actually because he was doing a podcast
he was the first wrestler to get a
podcast he's very good at it he's a
great interviewer
he's very curious he's such a good guy
too man great guy
i love him salt of the earth for sure
awesome dude
but he said they're looking for other
wrestlers and i said well i'll do a show
but i can't do
it just on wrestling that would drive me
crazy right what do you want to do my
i want my show to be like the tonight
show for example
i was a huge johnny carson fan and i
would watch every night no matter who
the guest was just because i love johnny
the way he did his interviews whatever
it may be
now if robin williams was on i'd be so
excited but if it was you know
[ __ ] i don't know diane lane or
something i'd still watch because it's
johnny
so i built my show around me as the host
and whatever the topic is and i have it
everybody lots of obviously lots of
wrestlers
tons of musicians comedians porn stars a
lot of paranormal stuff
you know surfer guys skateboard guys
whatever is interesting to me i'll have
them on
right and usually people check it out
even if they know nothing about the
topic
because they understand that i wouldn't
have them on unless i thought this
person was really
interesting and could tell a great story
and that's how i built the show
for sure man that's that's epic and yeah
it's kind of like dancing with the stars
you know you tune in because you see
they got one person that you're really
interested that's right then you fell in
love with the show did you do it
i did it so did i i know you you were
season 11. where were you
i was uh [ __ ] i think i was season nine
okay it was back in 2009 okay so i was
in 2011. what did you think of it
dude it was uncomfortable for me man was
it i mean i was like newly sober at the
time oh yeah
so like i was you know i mean i had
about one year of sobriety which still
makes for baby yeah like like
uncomfortable in my own skin
very self-conscious like emotionally
vulnerable
yeah yeah yeah it was a tough spot to be
uh
performing in front of 20 million people
doing you've got to put in a lot of time
too people don't understand like
if you don't spend no amount of time
would have helped me learn how to dance
like honestly like i i i wasn't like
lazy about it but dude
it just wasn't your thing my dog wendy's
not gonna learn how to dance either
who made it farther between you two i i
i lasted six weeks
that's good yeah i was i was the second
worst on the show
but you know what though and you know
this and you know i'm not talking out of
school because anybody that watches with
with the right mind will understand it's
show business sure right
so whenever they say that like these
these scores
are a combination of fan votes
and judges scores yeah and i would
always say well how much fan votes like
well we can't tell you that
i thought it was exactly 50 50. no no no
no no
dude they know exactly it's like
wrestling it's called booking
they know who they want to go where they
want stevo
obviously you're entertaining as [ __ ]
got a great fan base that's outside of
what they're
what they usually have but i bet you
that the housewives loved you
and that's why you went and started
getting uh like stopped by grandmas and
[ __ ]
i never had so many you know mid mid you
know 50 60's ladies come and talk to me
i did the same i realized early on the
more entertaining i can be
the dance is important but there was a
lot of times i did great dances
but they wouldn't give me the great
scores because they
they weren't ready to to give me those
tens right
right so every week when they give you
your little interview i would tell a
joke i'd find something funny to say and
like this
this guy's funny so i lasted at six or
seven weeks i can't remember which one
it was
but that's how i stayed on my dancing
was good it could have been
even scored better but i don't think i
was slotted at that level but i stayed
on because people
liked me that's what it is it's they
want you on to draw the ratings you know
i said did you feel like man i'm in a
like a metal band and i'm on dancing
with the stars
well i know it's like you're being
pulled in different directions well
here's the funny thing that some
people did kind of bag and you're not
like the real metal but at the time i
was hosting the golden gods awards which
they used to have at the nokia theater
and it was a heavy metal awards show and
during the show
alice cooper and geezer butler from
black sabbath both said
we voted for chris jericho and dance the
stars you should too because he's
he's a metal guy the further he goes the
better it is for heavy metal and then
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] are like [ __ ]
you were like yeah
go jericho yeah these are most like when
i met geezer he's like oh
hey geezer chris jericho i know you i
voted for you and dancing with the stars
that's great so did my wife and i was
like thank you mr butler [ __ ] the
greatest
riff rider ever
so yeah so the guys those guys get it
you know dude the bigger the stars
the better the people like they're
always the biggest star is always the
[ __ ] coolest because they got nothing
to be worried about right like like
alice is the is the sweetest guy like
of course you should do dancing with the
stars why wouldn't you do dancing with
the stars
and everybody should be cheering for you
to do that i was like yeah
alice you know you never thought you'd
hear that from alice cooper but that's
those guys
feel it and see it that way i could
totally see you know yeah that's cooper
who won your guys's seasons it was uh so
this is another reason why i i could
tell that there's a little bit of
booking like i said so kirstie alley was
on the show she's [ __ ] so cool she's
the coolest chick
and she's she has a tendency she's
bigger and then she gets in shape and
she gets bigger
so her story was was going from a bigger
lady to getting wicked shape and she
really did
and then heinz ward is the football
player i think he's with pitchers
pittsburgh steelers so it came down to
those two now this was the year that abc
which is is the station that that dancer
stars runs on
right had just disney doing my disney
but they had just gotten the rights to
the super bowl in the nfl
okay so of course who wins all right nfl
guy
he won and i was like kirstie's totally
should have won because the point of the
show was she
bettered herself and got into this
wicked shape and then they still gave it
to the football guy and i'm like there's
no [ __ ] way in this football guy from
week one
and he's a good guy but i was like week
one my dad's killed his
and they gave him like three eighths i
got a six and a seven and a five i'm
like that's [ __ ] [ __ ] right off
the bat i'm like
i was way better than him what's the
difference hmm he's in the nfl
abc just got the nfl ah i get it
synergy right yeah wow who won your
season
um uh this is super sweet
olympian
[Music]
it could be 2009 the next year's 2010.
they're going right into it man
funny uh-huh so okay and i i'm always
interested in this
but with the the podcasting the music
the wrestling
the books the cruise ship the guys yeah
with the cruise ship wow so
what's how how do we rank the revenue
streams
well i mean when aew started like i was
very integral to getting it off the
ground
and that's where i got like once again
you're dealing with sports
people now in the khan family wwe is
dealing with the mcmahon family which
are wrestling people they think
differently than
a sports team puts together a team with
the stars and the you know
so i got a really great contract to go
to aw that was by far the most they'd
ever gotten so
revenue stream that's number one i mean
that makes perfect sense number one
i need you to legitimize that you're
right dude and that's why we got on tnt
i think because if you look at our
roster at the time
there was a lot of guys like darby who
we've made into stars over the last
night but at first like who was this guy
who's this guy i mean dude darby like
his talent is [ __ ] amazing and we saw
it right out of the gate oh this guy's
got something man he's right
he's he's got it it's tough for me to
watch him i feel like he's just so
who's that thing yes i feel like he's
gonna get so badly hurt every time i see
him it's either on that or the stunts
that he does on his vignettes that he
does man he's doing all this he did
he puts himself in a bodybag like
something you would do
when he was on the big vert wall oh yeah
yeah and he comes crashing down
his body bag dude with the body bag he
can't even see him in there i'm trying
to do
you can't even see that you're just
there yeah i said just put a mannequin
in there because it wouldn't be real i
said nobody thinks it's real anyways
it's wrestling
but uh but so that was the biggest
revenue stream because at first it was
just jericho and they knew jim ross
obviously
but other than that it was just a bunch
of guys that had great talent and
potential
but who can we're getting tnt who's
going to be recognizable well it's just
jericho
so that kind of that was the big revenue
stream podcasting has been very good too
because like i said i was able to get in
early and then
here's what you do man there's so many
podcasting platforms
and i had started with one called uh uh
what was it called uh
pod yeah westwood one yeah that's the
network it was called podcast one
yeah it's the original one and then when
my contract was up
suddenly you're a free agent and you
have all these numbers then suddenly
they start
you know here comes the offers that's
when i switched to westwood one
so that's what you want to do is build
up something build up your brand in this
day and age
everybody you mentioned content
everybody is looking for content
whether it's podcasting youtube
channel i have a youtube channel as well
yeah how long have you been doing that
uh that was
fairly early i haven't gotten uh i just
crossed 200 000 i think it's been about
a year and changed i got to work more on
that
because there's so much [ __ ] going on
right you gotta keep it's like spinning
plates you know
that's crazy man and i gotta get more
into the youtube but also too i have no
problem
like working with people that can help
me do that like you can't do everything
yourself
you know it's so hollywood like i have a
team you really do have to have a team
and if you've got the right people you
can really pump up this revenue
for sure like there's there's a dude who
started up um
uh my own kind of news site called web
is jericho it's it's mostly wrestling
but it's music it's paranormal
it's it's a new site you go to click on
the stories this [ __ ] thing is
bringing in like
six figures a year i don't do anything
other than let the guy do it he takes
his percentage and i'm like dude this is
like
we call it mailbox money right like if i
decided just to do [ __ ] all this year
i still have a six figure check just
from this guy posting stories on web as
jericho
that's what you want to do in this day
and age there's so many ways to do that
so many revenue streams you just have to
stay on top of it all and it's hard
but you can do it if you have the right
people helping you you know i i
constantly get offers from people they
see like i've got like a
large audience on facebook they're
always they always say
dude let us partner with you on facebook
and we'll create all this content we'll
post like 10 times a day you're you're
interviewed
and i just can't give up the reins i
can't get remains for people to post
on my [ __ ] but uh but i hear about all
this money that could be made and i'm
just like it's not that important
i feel like i've worked so hard to build
my
audience you know like with [ __ ] that i
make and then
you know that's like yeah there's
integrity in it and i just can't
the thing is too though steve is you can
like and i have a lot of those types of
things where i keep them in my back
pocket like
if something maybe doesn't work out in
one of these other streams okay maybe
then i'll focus more on this
youtube and you know like you said
facebook or whatever because i got the
same thing
you can monetize this money you can do
patreon you can do twitch it's like i
don't
i don't want to i don't want to like i
have a youtube show that i do with two
of my friends from high school we call
it the winnipeggers because we're from
winnipeg canada it's great it's just
three old friends and we pick a topic
every week we've got a bunch of little
gimmicks and
it's fun it draws you know about 20 000
a week
you should monetize it but like i don't
want people to have to pay to see this
right this is a chance for me to drink
with my friends that i don't get to see
especially with the [ __ ] lockdown you
can't get into canada right
it's it's a good time it's good for my
soul it's fun
there's the word fun so i don't need to
monetize it i want people to watch it
and have fun with us and that's how we
built it up
maybe we'll get some ads at some point
but for right now this is fun for me and
if it's fun for me if it's fun for you
people that enjoy what we do will have
fun with it too and that's the thing it
doesn't always have to be about the
money
right but if it ever came down to that
then you could focus more on those types
of things
until then you don't need to monetize
your facebook yeah your facebook is
there for people that are fans of you to
go and check out what the [ __ ] you're
doing right
i love it you know so yeah you're
from winnipeg not calgary no i grew up
in winnipeg and i moved to calgary to
train for wrestling
got it so that was the difference
because there was the the hart brothers
uh family bret hart and owen hart they
their family had a wrestling school that
was kind of like the place to go
if you wanted to get trained properly
right because you do have to get trained
properly that's how you learn how to be
a good wrestler by
by the foundations that you learn when
you're training sure yeah
do you naturalize or you became an
american citizen later
no so like my dad played for the new
york rangers wow
so yes i was actually born in new york
oh there you go
yeah so we would spend we would spend
the hockey seasons in new york and then
st louis when he got traded
and then the offseason would be winnipeg
where he's from so because i was born in
the states and my parents were canadian
i'm a dual citizen
they always have been my mom was born in
canada you're doing so i'm canadian
yep my dad was born in america some
american i was born in
england oh you're a triple so you're a
triple yeah triple national that's
killer
yeah i love it that's so you never had
to worry about like i never worried
about work visas to go from canada to
america when i was young
right yeah with my criminal record i
would never be allowed in canada
canada's like canada they're super
strict yeah australia too yeah if you
have a dui
we'll [ __ ] with you to get into canada
sure yeah well let me let me ask you
this because we asked
george shane pierre this question if you
get hurt in a wrestling match
would you rather go to a canadian
hospital or an american hospital
you know when you go to the hospital in
canada it's free
so maybe here in america we should be
embarrassed about paying for medical
care
but i'll tell you what i'm really
embarrassed about is how much i
used to spend on ridiculously overpriced
shaving products with a bunch of stuff
that you just don't need
like the vibrating which is actually
worse
for your shave man i'm embarrassed about
that
but fortunately i found out about
harry's shaving products
which are every bit the quality of any
other shaving products on the market
we're talking about a killer
five blade razor that is absolutely
top of the line man and since i found
out about harry's it's all i've used
for well over a year i swear i use no
shaving products except for hairs
and i got a deal for you that's crazy
you're gonna get a shaving kit starter
kit
everything you need five blade razor
weighted ergonomic handle
foaming shave gel and this killer
travel case so you're nice and safe and
sound
how do you get it well you go to
harry's.com
h-a-r-r-y-s dot-com
stevo and that whole starter kit which
is a 13
value is yours for only three bucks
and i'm telling you once you use this
you'll never go back either
so much more affordable every bit as
good as
any other product so one more time go to
harry's
dot-com stevo get your 13
starter kit for only three bucks
there you go now let's talk about
hospitals
i think what if you're talking to a high
level athlete which
makes me laugh even thinking about
working working and wrestling you know
your body very well
so you need to find a specialist for
whatever your problem is
that's the most important answer did he
say that too
yeah so it doesn't because there's
there's great doctors in both countries
but what is your what is your issue
if you [ __ ] up your knee you want to go
to birmingham dr james andrews he's got
the best
kind of clinic down there if you screw
up like a [ __ ] shoulder joint there's
guys in tampa who are great
there's guys in in canada who know a lot
about like
when brock lesnar had diverticulitis he
went to a canadian doctor that was a
specialist
so it kind of all depends on what your
ailment is most people don't know that
oh i hurt my hand i'm gonna go to the
general doctor and they'd put a cast on
and nothing [ __ ] changes
you hurt your hand you need to go to a
hand doctor who understands you're an
athlete you need this hand
back it's true right yeah like i have a
buddy that just got his hand
like [ __ ] mangled mangled shark oh
wow by a shark
you must have some crazy buddies man
yeah well we were bombing an
episode for shark week are you allowed
to talk about it yet probably not so he
got that
but it got it got him huh yeah
they're running with it you know do you
do you dive are you scuba diving
i'm a paddy's certified okay so so me
too my son and i as well we were just in
hawaii last week and it's awesome scuba
diving is so great but i'll tell you
what man
when those [ __ ] sharks like they
they're always very tame
always every single movie you've ever
seen
jaws and everything else and you know
the 47
meters under all those [ __ ] movies
the shark just hangs out
and and there's some big there's a nurse
shark there's a reef shark
i don't give a [ __ ] what the name of it
is it's a shark for sure
you are in its house it's in the shape
of a shark if it decides
to do anything you got nothing you can
do you're just sitting there going
please don't kill me shark these sharks
were in a gnarly feeding frenzy we were
[ __ ]
throwing meat they were climbing over
each other if i could chop
so you're asking for a [ __ ] leaf
landed on the water they swarmed it
were you the one that put a bunch of
[ __ ] meat in a like a like a steel
jock and had the shark eat the [ __ ]
jaw
it wasn't that was that knocks that guy
i had was you thought
chicken and a jock strap with an
alligator
and you have to do that so i remember
when uh when i first got hurt when i was
still living in calgary i went to the
doctor for the calgary stampeders
and he said okay he said let me ask you
a question how much time do i have
to get you better because i know you're
an athlete i know you're going to do it
anyways
so when's your next i was working in
japan a lot then when's your next tour
we call it uh it's in six weeks okay so
i have six weeks to get this i can't
remember if it's my shoulder or my knee
i've got six weeks to get this as healed
as it can
because i know you're gonna go anyways
right and that's what you want a guy who
understands what an athlete says his
most talked about
[ __ ] for four to eight weeks that's
just the way it is and it's to come back
and say like
we don't work that way dude i've got
like you know a week and a half
you got to [ __ ] fix it to go and real
sports therapists will get that and
sports doctors will get that that's why
you want those types of guys
because most of the specialists are
former athletes themselves
so they understand most general
practitioners are just dudes that went
to medical school
and they learn a little bit about
everything you can't go there with a
specific sports injury
and expect them to [ __ ] make it
better like like a specialist can
what's the worst injury that you've ever
had during a wrestling match you just
had
you remember that though dude that's
good yeah yeah he's actually right i've
been very fortunate in not having um
you know i could not have knocked on
what a thousand times but i've never
uh missed a match ever from injury
except for the one time when i broke my
arm
and i was out for six weeks and that was
a perfect example they said you're out
for
12 to 16 weeks like i got a [ __ ] i
missed one tour but back then if you
missed too many tours that you would
just lose your job
so i had the steel plate put in there
and um
and i what i was doing is i said if i
just eat it like the bone has to
heal if i eat a lot of calcium will that
help and the guy's like
like probably not but like whatever so i
was like okay so i bought a bottle of
calcium a day
and you'd eat these [ __ ] things
they're just like there's only so
there's like 60 in a bottle i was
shoving them down my [ __ ] throat
right lo and behold i go back in two
weeks the bone
is is like almost healed wow he goes
which i said i ate like a [ __ ] bottle
of
calcium pills a day he goes i can't
believe it it worked i'm like then why
why would you say it's not going to work
who knows
give it a try know i was so excited it
[ __ ] works so if anyone's broken
their arm
eat a lot of calcium pills and maybe
it'll work i gotta believe too that it's
really good to do with your your mental
your frame of mind absolutely and
meditation like is a big deal i think
too like i'm meditating i think that
that's uh
i agree with you i started doing yoga
about
10 years ago right after dancing with
the stars actually i kind of threw my
back out
obviously 20 years of resting leading up
to that didn't help but
um yoga worked so well for me
because i wanted it to yeah yeah a guy
called ddp
mcdonald's you know he created his own
yoga i did yoga with him okay
there you go i'm sure he ran into he's
serious about it and i was getting some
acupuncture done i posted it on social
media he called me we were never like
tight
but he said you got to do this yoga i'm
like yoga's for hippies and gurus he's
like dude i'm telling you
if you do this it will help you
and i was like whatever i went to sit
down right when i was talking to him i
had this
saw blade pain and i was like okay i'll
try it i'll try try it and lo and behold
man it was super hard at first and about
a month in it's got a little better
three months later completely cured and
i had three doctors say you need back
surgery
gone with the yoga but i wanted it to
work
and that's what paige said too you have
to believe it you know so there is a lot
of mental to it
and yoga was a form of meditation for me
because when you drop right into it
you just feel nothing but your body and
mind together it sounds like hippie
[ __ ] but it really is the truth yeah it
works now the breathing too like
focusing breathing
stretching remember the one is like you
hold your hands up and he said imagine
all of your energy going out of the tips
of your fingers
and you would you stretch out as far as
you can i still do it sometimes and you
can really feel
the energy coming from your legs up
through your head
through your tips your fingers and we're
not even stoned here guys this is true
this is true story stuff right well at
least i'm not
but so you're right the mental does
tie in with the physical and you have to
have the right attitude and
and both will heal as a result yeah now
let me ask you this
ah i always say
that my canadian passport is
among or if not like my
most treasured possession oh yeah
well yeah and and it's not you know i
mean i'm super grateful
for you know to be american to live in
america
all of my travels people ask me like uh
where do you like traveling the most you
know i'm like i don't know i like
traveling but i'm
always so stoked to come back yeah
like i like america yeah yeah but with
that said
the way that the american government is
basically a ponzi scheme with all the
borrowing all the debt yeah
people ask people act as if uh as if the
debt doesn't have to be paid back and it
does yeah and like
at some point there's going to be like
that like a a real moment
economically yeah and i feel like it's
not going to be so bad in canada
and uh and and i want to like be set up
over there
you know the thing is canada to me was
always and once again i'm like you i
live in america i work in america
my family is american and i love it uh
canada has always been pretty pandemic
the pandemic for them has been really
bad it's
they're still locked down and like i
haven't seen my dad in 18 months because
he lives in manitoba
where they're still [ __ ] locked down
it's it's the shits
but um pre pandemic and hopefully post
canada has a different vibe than the
states if you tell anybody you're
canadian
there's always a certain attitude and
it's always good
like if you go to europe and you tell
someone you're canadian hey canada
that's great tell someone you're
american then i'd be like oh great
there's always something about canada
people are kind of friendlier maybe
they're a little bit more open
um they're neutral just neutral yeah
just more
there's there's just a vibe and when you
go up there it's just
more laid back i mean i'm not saying
there's not problems but
i never shot a gun in my life until i
moved to the states there's really
nobody has guns there i mean they might
but it's not like here where everybody
has a gun and there's
target practice and all this other stuff
just little examples of
it's just it's just a friendlier place
do you have a home in canada
i don't i don't here's the thing like i
when i first started working for ted
turner in the 90s
you couldn't live in canada and work in
america
because you get taxed twice so if you're
paying you know i don't know 40
tax in america you'd have to pay like 40
in canada
here's your 20 buddy go have a great
night right so you had to make your
choice and that also includes having a
residence in canada
maybe it's changing up at the time like
anything you have if you have an address
in canada
excuse me you're paying these these
increased taxes i got to look into that
yeah watch out for that because i got
plans to get
property in canada just make sure it
might have changed but you if you have a
residence there you get taxed as a
canadian citizen
and you don't want the double double
[ __ ] right i don't want that you don't
want that
but but having said that you know i
would go up to canada
and once again it's the worst thing for
the pandemic for me is i haven't been
gone up to canada because
all my family was up there my best
friends of up there i would go
ah i got a couple days off i'll fly to
calgary for a couple days go hang out
with my bros or
go see my dad in winnipeg and i haven't
been able to do that
uh in such a long time and that's one of
the worst things about the pandemic is
the
is the shutdown of the border for that
country so hopefully it opens soon
because it really is
it's a really cool place man it's the
vibe i love canada
yeah man me too i super love it when you
go to calgary and just get off the plane
and walk out of the airport just
you just smell the mountains and the
trees and yeah you can just
like go to portland like you can just
smell it when you get out there and
it's like no other place in the world
wow when you do the show with your
buddies
every week you're on zoom uh yeah we do
it on stream yard yeah
yeah yeah it it and once again it's just
one of those things where i had them on
one of my podcasts that i did and my
manager actually was like you guys need
to do a show together i mean the
chemistry of three
lifelong friends just shines through and
i said maybe we should try this so
we just started doing it and now like i
said we have a real flow to it and fan
mail and
i go on cameo every week and get a guest
and we get them to say
hello to the winnipeggers you never know
what you're gonna get with that and just
three dudes [ __ ] around and drinking
and having fun and sometimes
sometimes the shows are great sometimes
we're a little bit too drunk
but people don't care they're just
having fun you know what i mean if you
can't get too drunk with your buddies
but it really has been cool like i said
that's been a one good link
like had this pandemic happened five
years ago
our output and content and and
relationships would have been [ __ ]
even worse
yeah because you wouldn't have had zoom
to do meetings or
people would be scrambling everything so
at least we have this connection where
you can go and talk to somebody and see
their face
which really we really didn't do a lot
of that pre pandemic so that's one of
the
the positives of it i guess for sure
yeah for sure man so
with that with the book we're gonna
like how are people buying this book
it's jericho30.com
jericho 30 because yeah my 30th
anniversary is what we're dealing with
and like i said
people like is it gonna be in stores it
will not be in bookstores because i did
it myself
um but it's you know it like i said i
did a virtual signing last night it went
through the roof because
people that's a new thing too virtual
signings how do you do a virtual
assignment so what you do is
is uh they have a camera on you they
have another camera pointing there
when you're signing people can see you
actually signing
their book you know to steve you know
chris jericho le champion whatever they
want
so then that like it's a number
associated you ship that book to them
exactly and it's personalized it's first
line oh well [ __ ] i gotta figure that
out dude yeah
there's there's companies that do this
and and you don't even have to leave
your house man
what about merch do you do merch um yeah
i do i don't do
personal merch once again because let's
get into the category we talked about
earlier like
i don't want to be like a complete just
jericho store but we have so much merch
with aaw
fawzi i mean all the books all that sort
of stuff i don't have my own
web store which i'm probably losing some
revenue on that but once again
we can help you out with that oh there
you go see i need a team you can be on
my team
is packing fulfillment oh right on
[Laughter]
tight box packing that's the logo
i've seen that movie before it was like
skin of max
yeah i love it man like uh
selling merch on on my website it has
been
probably a huge business right yeah i
mean it depends like we're kind of
figuring it out
for a long time it wasn't huge business
but then we would try different stuff
certain things would work really well
you know over time it evolves and now
it's like really pretty great man
they design a lot of stuff too like i
spent a lot of time signing
yeah they want that physical you know
connection and that's why we used to do
a lot of
in stores with fozzie whenever we were
in a town
because people like the personal sure
hey how's it going dude that virtual
assignment
that's the way that that's the next
level that's next level fulfillment on
that yeah
it went through the roof like dude like
i'll tell you afterwards how many pieces
i signed and how much how much you can
make off it but
it was like it took me four and a half
hours to sign all this stuff and i'm
fast
yeah i'm a fast [ __ ] signer but two
of that was on the air
so i signed it i signed 2500 pieces
total
22.50 in two hours and then 250 in the
two hours of the virtual signing yeah
because then you got to take the time
and of course you should
of course never been the guy that just
signs and goes on but there's nobody
there so you can't really talk to
anybody
but you know that they want you to right
at least
spend some time with the signature yeah
sure right right but you got to be ready
man
and when you get on the camera and
people want can you sign this this this
this
and there's certain things that i just
won't sign like i won't sign you just
made the list
because every [ __ ] person
wants me to put them on the list i said
like four years ago
that's done you can't ask me to put you
on the list
you have to get on the list like
naturally because if i didn't say that
do you know how long it takes to write
you just made the list like [ __ ] a
thousand times
it's a long time right yeah so i yeah
that's the one thing i won't sign is you
just made the list
good yeah so uh so jericho30.com
get that damn book yeah what are the
people listening to this are thinking
man but i want it it's not made out to
me like are there going to be more
virtual signings
we'll probably do some more virtual
signings and i'll probably figure
out that's the one thing like because
it's self-published so that goes through
it's not like i have a you know 10 000
books in my garage that
it goes through kind of a broker but i
think i'll do another
signing and also too like this is a
lifetime
guarantee like any signing i ever do
from now on i'll sign the book like
obviously that's no brainer thank you
you see me on the street whatever the
[ __ ] it is a fawzi gig or whatever
i'll probably be signing this for the
rest of my life because people love that
you know like i said
in the old days old days the other four
books you would do
a book tour yeah so you would go to you
know carson noble
mobile you know there's jersey stores
there's ones you would do the whole
route there's one
camera the one is it bookends there's
one in jersey that every time you will
draw a thousand people it's [ __ ]
amazing
and that's where you just have to sign
go sign it because there's too many
people and you don't want to leave
anybody empty-handed
but so yeah that's kind of the there's
never like
to get a book signed it's it's kind of a
it's a cool to actually be able to get
it signed because not everybody gets it
sure right i mean i would say so if
there if there is can be another virtual
signing then uh
the best way for people to find that out
is going to be to follow you on social
media yeah i'm really
really engaged in social media instagram
twitter facebook so i think and you
probably know this too
i'm self-contained advertising at this
point self-contained promotion
because you can't really trust anybody
to do that anymore i just do it myself
and i haven't yeah i told you
you know we bought a tv ad or we bought
like that just do it all through
your social media and i think i have 14
million
total so i have a great system
you know and people respond and they see
it so uh that's why i just put up
everything on there but also too you
can't put everything up at once you got
to stagger it
like i've got programs or projects
scheduling posts yeah but also projects
that i can't even announce that i want
to
because i just don't have i can't you
can't put three or four things up in a
week it's too much
right like this is the book week we'll
leave that for a couple weeks then
we'll talk about the new t-shirt and
then we'll talk about maybe
the the maybe doing some cameo stuff
which is is
is probably the next step but do it
right you know what i mean like
i was reading up about it like the dude
from the office the bald guy brian
he made over a million dollars on cameo
last year
a million dollars and he charges like
150 bucks a shot
so i always hit that for a little bit i
just couldn't i couldn't
do it anymore like right and my but my
thing is
so how does he i love the office but he
was a minor character in the office
and it's not like he has other gigs i'm
sure he does
but cameo has now become gilbert godfrey
too
they have become like these cameo
wizards that are doing
over seven fingers figures a year how
how
what's the strategy here so i kind of
like i look into it and dig
deeper and think about like how does
this work
you know what i mean and so i talked to
the head of cameo martin
and we had a meeting just like if i'm
going to do it
i want to try and do more than these
guys so what's the cause you like
mayweather charges five grand
right nobody has five grand to get a
mayweather cameo maybe
maybe a few people people probably have
200 bucks that sounds like that's
expensive for for sure nowadays
but you know if i was wanting really to
get like you know
if mick jagger was on cameo for 200
bucks i'm you know my my brother wanted
it i would do it
you know if i just was working a day job
so how do you get people the word of
mouth and make this into this big
cottage industry so that's kind of
i like the challenges of it right right
and like the strategy
my problem was that every cameo i would
just like
with all my content i would like i i
would uh
turn the camera on to like a screen
where i would be showing like giving a
sneak peek of like some
super awesome unreleased clip yeah that
like was
it would be like you could and i would i
would put all this [ __ ] effort into
it
and then people would complain like nah
dude you didn't say it exactly with him
i know i'm like one guy ruined it for me
man
he was like i put so much effort into
making this awesome video he's like no
well dude i actually
said like quote you didn't put exactly
what do you know how much trouble i got
last night
on the on the uh virtual signing for not
writing you just made the list
like i just i'm not i got so much you
weren't right when we called you a week
i'm like dude if you were standing in
front of me i would say the same i don't
do it
i'll sign other things people get very
angry
sometimes like you said and and to me
my point was i could write exactly what
you want or i could do something
different that's just as good if not
better
right just be cool man like this is cool
[ __ ] that we got going on here you know
yeah
so i can see that with cameo too and and
i'm
one thing you like fans are awesome but
fans
like to complain yeah they do a lot and
that's great but
sometimes you go guys just stop it's
cool
life is great man it's all good you know
so so we definitely want
to promote your cameo well we haven't
started it yet i'm just i
haven't started it yet i'm working on
the research research and development
phase right now that research
make sure you're following chris jericho
on instagram facebook twitter
yeah you can find out when you can get
the camera yeah yeah exactly
get the book at jericho30.com.com
tune into aew yeah
that back on wednesday night starting
next week talk is jericho's the podcast
jericho's the pirates
auxiliary what about the cruise ships oh
that's another thing we could be here
another hour
yeah i started my own cruise a couple
years ago now when it's not to start
your own cruise what it is there's
existing cruise line and you kind of uh
book the ship for uh themed uh a themed
which it's a chris jericho rock and
wrestling rager at sea
yeah so what we did the fozzie played
the kiss cruise and i was like hmm
i could probably do my own cruise yeah
and levin had a cruise line
so i worked on it for three years to get
it up and running it's it's rock and
wrestling it's wrestling
at sea first time ever wow wow
we had to get engineers in there to
figure out how to how did the wrestling
personalities well just
everybody i got aw on there but i got
all the hall of famers every year it's a
different group right
and then there's rock and roll bands
there's comedians there's paranormal
[ __ ]
there's everything everything that i'm
into i put on this so cool
that's that's cool like i was saying we
had to get this team of engineers
and and then like there's like three of
these dudes that created these
these water ballasts that we put the
ring over top
these big cubes of like tons of water
that you put the ring over top in case
the
boat goes wonky right the ring doesn't
slide
but they had to spend time figuring out
this technology [ __ ] you never think
about right sure
yeah it's like the cup holder in the car
or if you're turning it
now imagine if you had to invent that
because i'm like i'm the idea guy i
never
think about how much it's going to cost
just [ __ ] put the ring on put some
chains it's like oh we can't do it we
have to we created water ballast so you
see the bill i'm like [ __ ]
i'm gonna be paying these off for the
next 10 years so that's why it has to go
for 10 years we've got number three
coming up in october
help me pay off my water balance today
that's epic
and dude like i i'm so like
blown away when i think that here i am
like pushing 50. i just turned 47. okay
and like i'm like going into a heyday
you know the fact that i've the fact
that i survived
past 30 years old blows my mind and then
here i'm thriving i'm doing all this
great stuff like
and and same thing with yeah man like
we're two guys that
that beat ourselves up for a living and
uh
we're [ __ ] here 50 years old like
killing it it's because we started using
our brains more than our bodies with
bodies was a great way to start
but i learned earlier like my body's
going to last
you know till here that's it gives me
goosebumps right the brains like dude
the stuff you can do like i was
i was not name dropping but we had mike
tyson come on our show and
mike and i had mike's sitting right here
the best guy best guy best guy
but he has done such a great job once
again what a great team he has
how much has he reinvented himself name
another boxer
including ali who has done as much as
mike has and kept at the top
level of celebrity just by being mike
tyson
right that's that's a a genius
uh example right right there and and
it's like
i feel the same with me with you we
started thinking outside the box
still being stevo still being jericho
but what can we do where we don't have
to you know
take these crazy falls and have sharks
eating shrimp off our nuts
it's okay to do that once in a while
right but like once in a while
the rest of the time let's do cool [ __ ]
like this and hang out in a van
in beverly hills at the parking lot of
the hilton and [ __ ] hang out man
there's nothing wrong with that
i love it man is there anything else we
can
direct anybody no all we got to do is uh
is
is uh at some point you got to come and
do talk as jericho because i want to
hear your story dude yeah yeah i love it
man
hey brother thank you hey awesome man
thank you steve thank you brother
thank you guys thank you thanks dude
there you have it folks did i tell you
that he was cool or
what man you know what else i love is
the fact that
old dudes can continue to be successful
man
that's just a wonderful thing hope for
the future kids
and as always i just want to thank you
for sticking around and watching to the
very end
i am on tour again i mean unless this
stupid pandemic shuts us down yet again
but check out my tour dates man come see
me on tour
[ __ ] yeah thank you guys